[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le match de la confirmation au Parc des
Princes à Paris devant les Suisses
commence bien très bien même pour les
footballeurs français les deux équipes
jouent un maillot foncé mais on
reconnaît les Français à leur bassombre
donc début de match extrêmement
favorable à la France durant 45 minutes
les Suisses sont à l'épreuve et l'on
s'attend au pire lorsque le petit ailier
gauche Buron marque le premier
but un premier but qui semble ouvrir la
voie à toute une série d'autres buts
d'autant que l'autre ailiier français
lèche le benjamin du match il a 18 ans
marque une seconde
fois on s'attente à une catastrophe pour
la Suisse et a tort 2è mi-temps
revirement total de la situation les
meneurs de jeu de l'équipe de France dou
en tête
s'effondre le résultat ne se fait pas
attendre la Suisse marque à son tour 2 à
1 et comme un malheur n'arrive pas seul
l'arrière gauche de l'équipe de France
blessé quitte le terrain à 10 contre 11
plus question pour les Français de faire
autre chose que de résister mais ils ne
peuvent pas éviter le match
[Applaudissements]
nul c'est un curieux sport qu'impose au
brave pou américain les impératif de la
productivité car c'est bien de
production de à la chaîne qu'il s'agit
dans ce toulailler modèle de Californie
élevé à la dignité d'usine comme dans
n'importe quelle usine l'automation est
rine première opération distribution de
la matière
première pas de perte les surplus sont
récupérés deè opération récupération par
tapis roulant toujours des produits
finis la production des œufs en Amérique
a vraiment atteint son plus haut degré
de rendement on comprend devant une
telle productivité la guerre du
poulet les armes se sont tues sur le
front du désert à figig même où le
conflit algéro-marocain avait semblé
reprendre après le cessfeu déterminé par
l'accord de bamaco les forces marocaines
ramènent à son climat de paix de paix
armé tout de même l'oasis hier encore
troublé par les
combats
c'est pour constater le respect du CESS
le feu qu'une commission des Nations
unies dans laquelle 10 nations étaient
représenté est venu jusqu'à figig en
compagnie du général marocainoufar
s'informer sur place sur toute la ligne
de ce qui fut le front du désert le
calme règne
[Musique]
dormet voici les images tournées dans le
feu de l'action lors du coup d'État de
saon et qui montre dans leur éloquente
brutalité les phases de cette
insurrection les forces insurgées
convergeant vers le palais présidentiel
au milieu des coups de feu et des
incendies c'est l'atmosphère de
révolution et de guerre de rue de cette
fin du régime
[Applaudissements]
d'EM le soir du 2 novembre le buste
mutilé du président sa garde prisonnière
après une résistance acharnée les
vainqueurs portés en triomphe par une
foule en fiévrée affirmait la victoire
totale de la jeinte des généraux cette
victoire n'allait pas sans le cortège
habituel de débordement populaire
désordre pillage et
incendie l'opposition au régime déchu a
pris ce jour-là toutes les formes
acclamation pour les bonses libéré des
prison et outrage au buste de Madame new
jeté au ruisseau mais depuis est rentr
dans le
[Applaudissements]
CAL quand un cosmonaute épouse une
cosmonaute tout se passe comme pour le
commun des mortels c'est ce qu'on
démontré à Moscou Adrian nikolev et
valentinaova à ce détail près que la no
s retrouvé au palais des réceptions dont
Monsieur a fait les honneurs au deux
belles mamans très ému avant de lever
son ver au bonheur des épou voilà en
tout cas une raison de croire que la
race des cosmonautes ne s'éteindra
pas
[Musique]
mieux informé mieux défendu contre la
tuberculose tel est le thème qu'évoque
le nouveau timbre qui vient d'être remis
au ministre de la Santé publique à
l'occasion de l'ouverture de la 33e
campagne nationale contre le terrible
fléo un fléo qui aujourd'hui 100 ans
après la naissance de Calmet inventeur
avec Guérin du BCG tue encore six fois
plus en France qu'au Danemark où le
vaccin est appliqué systématiquement
depuis longtemps ce sera le mérite de la
nouvelle campagne de rappeler à tous
qu'il existe un vaccin efficace et
simple et qu'il est criminel de le
négliger par passivité ou par
[Musique]
ignorance
laabéie pour beaucoup ce nom n'évoque
pas autre chose qu'une rue célèbre de
Paris une de ces rues aujourd'hui
encombré de voitures dont les trottoirs
sont voués au shopping et sans doute
assez peu d'entre ces flamemeuses se
doutent seulement qu'il exista un
certain Étienne de la
né à Sarla en 1530 et mort 33 ans plus
tard voici justement 400 ans c'est ce
nom qui unit étonnant jumelage l'une des
plus fameuses artères parisiennes à la
petite cité pégourdine endormie dans un
passé dont elle ne renit rien ni les
jolis toit de l'OSE ni les poivrières
d'angle ni les vieux porches qui ont
peut-être vu enfant ou jeune homme celui
qui devait passer comme un météore dans
le ciel littéraire de son temps et dont
le nom n'a surtout survécu que parce
qu'il fut l'amis de choix de Montaigne
ce qui lui inspira cette définition de
l'amitié si l'on me presse de dire
pourquoi je t'aimais Je sens que cela ne
peut s'exprimé qu'en répondant parce que
c'était lui parce que c'était moi c'est
dans cette ville silencieuse où tout
choses et gens est presque resté tel
qu'il le connut de la lanterne des morts
au marché aux oies qu'il est sans doute
plus facile de retrouver cet homme qui
promettait tant et qui mourut si jeune
sans remplir les promesses de son unique
ouvrage le discours sur la servitude
volonéire
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
peut-être écrivit-il quelques chapitres
de son œuvre entre les murs de cette
maison où il naquit et qui abrite
aujourd'hui étrange destin la Caisse
d'Épargne 400 ans après sa disparition
on l'imagine ce jeune pensif comme l'un
des flambeaux trop vite éteint d'une
époque à d'idée comme un esprit qui eut
ouvert des portes sur l'avenir il reste
dans son inachèvement comme le disait
Montaigne une âme qui montrait un beau
visage à tout
[Musique]
sens ce latin du miracle 24 heures après
le sauvetage de trois mineurs dans la
mine de pine la tour de forage s'est
remise en action dans la nuit 4 km plus
loin un forage d'exploration avait
permis de repérer 11 mineurs encore
prisonniers à 56 m de nouveau l'espoir
régnait sur la mine un deuxième forage
plus important fut réalisé il devait
permettre de descendre des vivres et du
matériel de première
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
urgence le troisème forage celui du
sauvetage était aménagé pour permettre
le va et vien de la
nacelle les 11 hommes seraient sauvés la
pause des tubes protecteur n'était plus
qu'une affaire de
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
routine et c'est sous le regard d'une
foule muette d'émotion qu'apparaissait
enfin sorti de la nacelle d'acier le
premier escapé hein Schul père de 10
enfants minute bouleversante où chacun
semblaêtre aidé du regard la silhouette
titubante au visage creusé d'un homme
qui avait passé 14 jours en muré vivant
[Musique]
puis de 5 en 5 minutes c'était un
nouveau mineur que la ncelle rendait à
la lumière crue un nouveau rescapé
qu'une famille des larmes de joie plein
les yeux
attendait mais les familles devaient
encore attendre chacun de ces hommes
durement éprouvés par 369 heur de
clostustration ne pourrait que lentement
revenir à la vie normale dans une
chambre
d'hôpital en 1 heure c'était fini
et la joie n'a pu s'empêcher d'éclater à
pain où les drapeaux sont restés en
berne car il y a tout de même 29
[Musique]
m